المشاهدين مع الحديث الاوكراني عن تعزيزات
الروسيه في البحر الاسود تتحضر روسيا لضم
غواصات نوويه جديده الى اسطولها البحري
مما يشكل تحديا دفاعيا للولايات المتحده
والنيتو وفقا نيوزويك اكبر شركه لبناء
السفن في روسيا والمنتج الوحيد في البلاد
للغواصات التي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه
ستزود البحريه الروسيه اذا
بغواصتين جديدتين الامبراطور الكسندر
الثالث
هذه الغواصه اذا الجديده كذلك في نهايه
العام الجاري غواصه الامبراطور الكسندر
الثالث مشاهدينا حظيت باهتمامي الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين شخصيا العام الماضي
ورفع عليها العلم الروسي في التاسع
والعشرين من ديسمبر الفائت هذه الغواصه
النوويه مشاهدينا هي قادره على حمل 16
صاروخا باليستيا عابرا للقارات وهي سابع
صواريخ من عائله بوري اي ومن المقرر بدء
التجارب البحريه عليها في يونيو المقبل
كجزء من برنامج التسلح الحالي في روسيا
لضمان امن البلاد في السنوات القادمه وفقا
لما اعلنه الرئيس الروسي هذا فيما يتعلق
بالغواصات الروسيه اما على الجانب الاخر
الجانب الامريكي القوه البحريه الامريكيه
المتمثله باسطول اوهايو
لديها اربعه عشره غواصه مشاهدين ويشار
اليها باسم بومرز وكل غواصه نوويه من هذا
الاسطول تحمل ما يصل الى 20 صاروخا
باليستيان برؤوس حربيه متعدده وموجهه بشكل
مستقل كما انها تمتلك ثلاثه فتحات ذات قطر
اكبر تسمح بالنقل السريع لمنصات الامداد
ووحدات استبدال المعدات ومكونات الالات
بما يسمح بوقت اقل عند التجديد والصيانه
[موسيقى]